the [ __ ] is karma like wait a minute so
you're telling me like if you do lots of
good things that weirdly good things
happen to you yeah that seems like
common sense
i will say this i believe that karma is
the single most practical energy in the
world would it not make sense to our
practical brains that if you're doing
something good for somebody else that
that puts you in a leveraged position
for something good to happen to you like
doing the right thing is always the
right thing that is actually how humans
work it's why we're still here humans
are inherently phenomenal this is what's
so [ __ ] me up about our culture right
now like people are so confused right
now because there's so much political
tension there's so much anger there's so
much stuff going on in our world
pre-coveted that people are super
confused like the way you actually win
is by doing all the nicest [ __ ] humanly
possible like nice guys
win like this whole like nice guys you
know finished last makes me laugh it's
just not true
nice guys might be losing at halftime
but they win the game
nice guys always win and the people that
are listening down be like not for me
everybody takes advantage of me
you're manipulating you're doing things
that look kind because you want
something in return true kindness pure
kindness is undefeated we're in a world
where a lot of thoughts of
collaborations and things you do you're
thinking about what comes to you after
you do giving without expectation has
been one of the core pillars of my
success you know why i'm so happy
i have zero expectation of others
nobody's ever let me down it's insane to
me
how little somebody lets me down i
helped somebody get into a deal it was
closed i reopened the deal got them in
they made millions of dollars on a fifty
000 investment a couple years later my
second book came out i said yo bro can
you buy a bunch i'm just trying to sell
as many as possible
dude it had nothing for me i made a
millions of dollars
other people i met one time one time and
they were buying hundreds everybody's
different but i would tell you it was
stunning to me how much it didn't bother
me i took note because i knew i could
tell this story one day right and i knew
that it would be a great lesson but it
it was i was unfazed because that's just
the way it is you can't live by giving
without expecting anything in return and
then knowing i always tell people karma
is practical
[Music]
you